okay I'm ready okay are you yeah okay
citizens of the reject Nation apparently
we're both ready to watch the monster
house it's animated we don't know
nothing about it I have never heard this
know what this it's just really
recommended and it's spooky spooky time
spooky season I love it so don't forget
to leave a like and leave a comment and
also ring the
bell ring the bell
that was like a spooky Opera everybody
loved it don't I know it five stars
listen gr can you plug some shirts
before I talk about I would love to plug
some shirts hey ladies and gentlemen I
want to say thank you to everyone who
watches our videos and who has also been
supporting the channel by getting
yourself some real rejects apparel at
www. reation shop.com we got shirt it's
like this one space babies of the Galaxy
just launches Ahsoka lightsaber scissors
snip snip if you get it you get it also
got our aoda shirt we got this one a
Pedro pass SC from Last of Us carrying
baby grou little combination Child
Protection Services what we call that
tea we also got who influences the
influencers watching insire and we got a
whole bunch of other te's as well that
are being flashed up on screen right now
and it is an amazing way to support the
channel and also look good while you're
doing it I love everything I heard and
I'm really upset they haven't given me
the groger one every time I'm here I ask
for Merch do you guys see me in the
millions of videos that I made so far
have I had any merch on no I haven't
whose fault is that look right here look
right here Bingo me Bingo baby plug the
patreon super sexy rejects don't forget
that you can watch the full reaction and
and sync up with your sync up with your
own copy on patreon and you can watch it
with me and Gregory Monster House sync
up the whole thing but also don't forget
that GRE and John do exclusive
highlights and and Reaction watch the
locks over there okay are you ready to
watch Monster Haw watch monster house
I'm ready to do it okay let's do
it
[Music]
Amin oh this is going to be a fun spooky
time fun spooky child Wonder oh my God
I'm ex extra excited now that that logo
not know amlin was involved with this
hey hey hey
baby cool title I love
that o intriguing opening thought
summertime
uh bye- bye
Leaf oh whoa cool camera moves there's
like only in animation can you do a
great tracking shot track shot of a Lea
so great waa I hope the next 90 minutes
we're just following this
Leaf this is Terror before we F me this
[Laughter]
morning I love how the color palette
does feel Halloweeny
yeah oh my God yeah I was like I hope it
ends soon but also she's
adorable get up Leaf get
up I think I feel so much danger about a
leaf that must be the monster house it
looks so spooky I've never seen this
type of animation before like the way
that she looks looks like almost like a
mixture of a video game and something
else to
me
wa
what my
Lord It's actually kind of creepy get
out of
here my TR
yeah what mean old old man what a meanie
old man
man whoa who the C these camera Jitters
are something else yeah this is shot
very cinematically for an animation
like whoa Cool October 30th another
tricycle I'm
coming what another tricycle it's almost
like a rear window situation mom he did
it again he took another tricycle you
cannot stay up in your room all day
staring at an old man through a
[Laughter]
telescope I'm
serious I'm a man his voice sounds funny
creek lady she's a brilliant
actress and I forget her name right now
Elizabeth will be here in a few hours if
anything happens call the police and
hide your closet
know see you tomorrow now
[Applause]
oh my God child murder it's hard to see
with the mask on then why don't you keep
it off chowder tell him you love him
dear please he knows that son you love I
don't want to tell him love love you son
he
knows I don't want to tell him I love oh
my God a cheer up it's almost Halloween
in one day in 3 hours it's candy time I
wonder if this takes place in an earlier
era it seems like the
the babysitter will be here in 3 hours
yeah I don't think I'm going
trick-or-treating this year okay what
I'm getting too grown
up oh my God it's time for an in your
face
disgrace oh
yeah where's my
ball there's something so disorienting
about the camera
work
he's going to take
it is there a blend of map with this see
that's why I was like this and the way
how smooth it is your B just landed on
NE Cracker's lawn it doesn't exist
anymore I paid $28 for that ball that is
expensive asked my mom for a126 times
never worked that hard in my
life that is so funny
oh man the fear of getting the ball from
the neighbor's yard God I've once had to
hop a backyard
before why is he always he's just right
always right there and
ready oh property
[Music]
damage dang he's a strong old man oh my
God what just terrorize my Lord not a
playground for children got it from now
on this is my
house you just stay away from oh no oh
you didn't die let him die do it
mofy what this child witness the horrors
of death as he looks in his
eyes
oh
gnarly shot the boldness on this
animated movie did he just die on top
him him yes bold move I respect it
wow maybe he was protecting maybe he was
keeping something like guarded in here
oh and he's actually not a bad guy after
all yeah he kind of reminds me of the
Home Alone guy and then you realize the
long guy is actually nice Yeah Joe peshi
was all right in the end not that one
the neighbor
dummy what is he not dead what's going
on he's not dead might have been too
Bleak if they killed an old guy within
dying on top of the little boy as who
watch the soul leave him it is called
monster house though respect though man
a golden key all right attached to that
house oh oh there's some there's a power
with the
house it eats things it's some kind of
monster house he shed it he sh
it cool all right so maybe the old guy
was really just trying to protect the
kids so they wouldn't get eaten by the
monster
house I'm a
murderer no you're not the cracking of
the glass is symbolic too for the boy
it's z z now listen up I'm not your
mother I'm not your friend don't talk to
me like I'm a baby okay this is her
first time babysitting I don't even need
you
[Music]
here oh Elizabeth DJ why you break that
but I didn't yeah let me ask you
something who are they going to believe
go to your room she's harsh I mean this
in a really complimentary way I feel
like I'm watching someone's like like
someone learn how to animate and put it
together themselves
[Laughter]
like this their artistic Vision come to
life in a way there's something that
feels like really intimate about the way
it's all drawn and kept
together like the Tim buron of old when
you're stepping into strange person's
Dark Fantasy
mind what hell yeah let's go okay all
right oh great changing down that is
awesome what
how
horrific yo this movie's
[Music]
committed what it's coming for your soul
that's awesome like it's night marish
expression it at the same time I really
thought I thought it was just going to
be like a cute little animated movie and
it's like this is way better way denser
than
that
[Music]
yeah very funny see how you like it star
69 yeah call them back this is
Satan is it coming from inside the house
or across the street that's a loud phone
if it's across the street street right
they need to soundproof those
walls this is the80s they don't know how
to do that so when your neighbor's phone
rings you can hear
it
happy Halloween doofus the Z boyfriend
look at his face that's
funny oh my God I think that guy looks
terrifying who's this this is Bones
what's up I think she is Skull and he's
bones no no no this is different
listen uh wow you called The
Neighbors he died now I'm getting phone
calls from his house a phone call
from Beyond the Grave that sounds cool
give her back oh her you
mind e yeah I think she's having trouble
breathing she might have something in
her throat all right I'll look into
it okay oh dud I can't wait you a jerk I
hope he dies by Monster House
immediately you are so funny oh my God
she sucks too if she thinks that's funny
I know I hope they die terrible death
girl get a personality
why would this old man and be there for
such an entity chck where are your
parents my dad's at the pharmacy and my
mom's at the movies with her personal
trainer that's so funny this movie is
very funny I love the writing of this
it's like it's kind of like comedy in
this it's not a Kids film it's oh no
gosh Maybe neor cracker really did die
the guy is evil no he's just a crotchety
old dude oh and they know of him when I
was 10 years old I had a kite one day it
crashed down I followed the string
across the street right at the edge of
his lawn uhhuh did he take your kite
yeah he takes whatever lands on his lawn
said I saw him talking to his house and
kissing it what
besides the house is alive so he like
loved his own house he at
her stop it wow there's like so much
lore here I'm ready to unpack that me
get
out the hell just happened what it
escalated right then and not when he
tore the insides of the bunny out did he
try to go for it he I mean he must have
tickled her a little too hard throw it
on the lawn
they do a good job at keeping this house
is like domineering presence in this
whole neighborhood yeah the like the low
angle shot of like making the house just
look so
[Music]
huge watch it be swallowed great
reflection shot that's awesome you
really are dead aren't you there's a lot
of
like um inanimate items that are feel
alive
here you're a your
kite and it's so neon and lit
[Music]
up oh I'm itching for them to go explore
the house never crackers haunting me all
right his blood is on my hands and now
he's coming back for Revenge you're
really crazy right now have you noticed
that I think you're just freaking out
because he killed a guy
today is this how they handled someone's
someone dying psychology when in the'80s
when you were like 30 yeah you're just
like somebody died move on like give it
an hour and just you know on I'll go
dingdong ditch the house and you'll see
no ghost stop please I'm serious come
back come back here super knows that a
toy with him crawling on the
grass nom nom nom M feel like the
neighborhood would be kind of gathered
talking about this event I thought the
same thing about DJ's parents and they
just were like oh yeah he likes a spy in
the weird
[Applause]
house all right buddy ditch dang dong
ditch
wow
wa
oh my
God W that's that looks
awesome Don't Look
Back damn that crazy that's great so you
can hear a phone ring but no one could
hear children screaming their heads off
in this neighborhood or the growl of an
entire
home maybe the parents you work for left
you $40 in emergency money maybe they
left me 30 I read a receipt for 30 and
you pocket 10 I want two extra bags of
peanut clusters one bag this babysitter
looks so much older like she looks like
she's like late 20s yeah I mean she has
to be right I mean she's listening to
skull and bones and dating a guy who
looks like he's 40 I know usually the
babysitters in these movies are like
yeah I brought you some
chocolate
chocolate cover
blown yeah like they cut into different
shot they're they do good like long
tracking shots but then the editing back
and forth to tell the story in this room
is like there's a lot going on yeah and
there's like the way they deal with like
where to like we the shots like where to
place the camera the perspectives yeah
have you two um seen bones I don't know
what to tell you your boyfriend has most
likely been eaten alive you said that
with the smile on his
face
love at first sight hello what is it oh
nothing let me
see I've never used the telescope or
binoculars to spy on a girl
before go don't go any further come here
are you guys mentally challenged can't
you hear that lady yeah come on
now
give it all your chocolate and run
away oh
boy oh whoa who how creative that's a
fun little
[Music]
ride I got her I got
hello please tell me she saw that she
had to have seen something I doubt it
does it only reveal itself to like
isolated adults and or children I guess
only reveals itself when it can capture
you the house they're trying to eat us
all right stop explaining I've had a
where you going I'm going to see what's
happening with that stupid House of
yours what is your problem I love that
sh it's like just they do like little
subtle things with the house to show
it's always watching I'm going to find
bones all right hey you have fun okay
don't worry about us we'll be fine hi
I'm JD
DJ it's almost like they choose to say
like if we're going to shoot this shot
even if it's 5 Seconds it better be
interesting yeah well there's there's
also something that feels semi vois
about the way it's done like there's
always someone the point of view is
always outside like through the car
looking at them was cool Charles to the
ladies um Jenny Bennett there's a great
taco stand near there I hate Mexican
food me too wow that's racist other
people make tacos too normally I don't
spend time with guys like you
but a house to eat me so first it was
the Mexican food comment now the like
you comment yeah girl where do you come
from a puppy please don't eat the dog if
the house eats the dog I going to be so
upset oh God you just made an no no it's
a doggy I think it's time to call the
police why yeah well I guess I guess cuz
it ate a dog with the rug that shot out
of its um door
mouth oh there
go that's a great that's awesome that's
so funny this house is the
devil it's going to be a blood
bath we have reason to believe that
there is a dangerous creature inside
that house it may have killed a man and
a dog call him a backup we don't have
backup it's just Judy at the station
this is no situation it's just a couple
tater tots hopped up on too many pixie
sticks is that Kevin James haer tots yes
time's up Peewee it's Halloween and
believe it or not we got things to do
take something that they have but if
things get out of hand throw it towards
the
house that's
lo I like how the house actually has a
clever mischievous personality it's
cunning the three time TR State over 14
Thou Art dead de Champion his name is
Reginald scholinski but they call him
skull there is a stranger things Vibes
to it yeah which stranger things was
very Amin with man-made structures
becoming possessed by a human soul so
that the spe becomes merged with wooden
brick rare form of monster
domis but how did he how did he occupy
the house though he seemed like he had a
real relationship with it You' got to
strike at the source of Life the heart
maybe the old guy just lived there
before became a Monster House the
furnace is the heart if we want to put
out the fire we fill the dummy with a
few gallons of cold medicine feed the
dummy to the house house eats the
medicine house goes to sleep we get in
there dous the fire and get out I don't
want to steal drugs from my father I
don't want to go inside a monster and I
don't want to die I say it's worth a
shot yes I agree let's do it why are
they so determined to kill this thing
though I feel like there's a version
where you can easily get more people in
on this but they are so
intive why is her determination there
maybe because they saved
[Music]
her and what else has she got to do
she's selling chocolate bars out of a
wagon man I could go for some chocolate
I haven't really eaten today I'm so
hungry me too we I never get snacks here
oh well just tell me I'll give you some
snacks snacks oh yeah that's what I was
going to say I was like you guys need to
have like like uh you know put on a
disguise so the house doesn't know your
kids but it can see though kind of but
I'm like it's got eyes that's what I
like about it like the house is like a
SP it'll just know right that there's
kids in the trash can but then again
maybe not but I think they establish
that like its eyes are open when the
blinds are open right so right now it's
closed sleep may not know yet hting on a
vacuum
[Music]
smart Okay so yeah they have to wait get
out oh great shot
nice God Chow hide better behind the
trash
can
W
cool I think I'm going to go as trash
can guy I mean vacuum cleaner guys for
Halloween it's a great
costume I love that way it rolls it out
like a
tongue
well no uh all right kids out of the
trash cans let's go drop your weapons
huhuh pass them to me come
on I will shoot you I will shoot you you
guys are going to jail but officer
you've got to believe us we we are super
casts yeah that's why I live in a condo
is there really a reason to arrest like
you mean no I'm like what for a vacuum
putting a vacuum cleaner prop in front
of a
house sounds like the dangerous creature
I'm going to go check it
[Music]
out how are they going to get out of
that back seat once these cops are
eating by the house red spooky creature
I'm going
fly what you doing that is
a oh WAOW going to go get backup I
thought there was no backup I'm getting
Judy I'm getting
Judy but what does it do to you when you
go when it swallows you I don't know I
mean does it go into the fireplace and
that's why it's like the chimneys going
off do they get immediately um
cremated uh-oh climb out the back come
on oh you're getting br
inside finally we get to see what's up
in
there what if it's just a misunderstood
so that is so cool
looking guys come on let's go oh my God
you can get a splinter in here yeah I
mean oh finally if we find the heart we
put out the fire maybe we should examine
our other options we wait here and do
nothing until it wakes up and eats us
find the heart put out the fire got it
so this house just only wakes up to eat
then goes back to sleep I guess so I'm
not a lazy house like damn that is the
dream wake up to eat W to eat go back to
sleep gosh did you ever see a
wife people used to say he had one don't
be judgmental but he fattened her
up I mean it's just straight up
spooky maybe she's the
house
there right there shoot
him I think you got to go down there
yeah just jump down there and see what's
up oh oh it's like a gel it's a gel now
oh my God it is very inventive with how
he uses like all the household tools all
the elements all the things inside the
house light if those are the teeth and
that's the
tongue then that must be the uula the
what the little thing that hangs in the
back of your throat it's a girl house it
stimulates the gag reflex everyone has a
uula oh dude this is way too mature this
is an animated movie for
adults I really do love his commitment
to its horror aesthetic but I am so
craving peanut butter right and quietly
don't touch anything stay
together no no where did he go where did
he go through the
floor oh I'll save you oh it's
everything it's ever devoured
oh this just got so much more horror
movie than I ever expected knock oh no
it's a bunch of toys down there yeah it
kind of plays on that whole thing of
like when you lose something in the
neighbor's yard but yeah yeah and you
can never get it back yeah I think you
guys should have a look at
this
constant the giant T that's what he
turned his wife into uh I
mean you fattened her up that's what the
key locks the key come on DJ we don't
have time for this yeah we've got to
find a way out of here I mean they gave
you the key for a reason uh yeah I mean
you have a golden key you got to use the
lock also I would assume that the heart
belongs behind the heart lock y'all not
so smart for precocious kids oh my God
is that a dead late there she is he
really did eat her is she still like
alive buried
cement oh what they they pour cement
over her what I don't know is it I
always knew you were hiding something Mr
never
cracker dude you got to stop falling
onto these bodies oh that that's not
that is not some sturdy cement that was
like
what it's the away
oh she's actually quite skinny
underneath all that
yeah it's really cool how they make like
the pipes feel like the inside of organs
and stuff everything in this house feels
like it's living yeah there's like an
anatomy to
it dude why are you so
stupid you we already learned this
earlier why are you so stupid what is he
doing
why
killer
slinkies did he just yell killer
slinkies
yikes yikes
whoa oh okay so it is intentional I
couldn't tell it
first uh
[Music]
whoa chatter you yeah come
on and this feels like alien sci-fi with
that
[Music]
light yeah it also feels like
a cool video game that you would play
where you're like choose your adventure
and what are you going
to
[Music]
who oh it's pushing you out you out cuz
y'all are kids but where are the other
people then I mean maybe it needed to be
unlocked it needed the help another
great idea DJ I don't see you coming up
with any big Ideas oh yeah yeah and also
he just saved your life I'm going home
to make a pretzel sandwich how can you
be hungry you make a pretzel sandwich
I'm going home I
suck jeez oh at least it's an
ambulance
what this just got
spooky who is this what is
it oh my God he
lives he stole an ambulance he's not a
ghost he's not dead I'm not a murderer
he's still in his Hospital gun
yep don't you know what day this is is
that Steve Bushi yeah I'm just hearing
it now running out of time running out
of time honey I'm home maybe his soul
did get her soul did get dispersed
amongst the house in the house it had to
because he buried her ruffled down there
your windows are cracked but he he
unlocked it though they unlocked it the
house is her Mr NE cracker
I know about
Constance this is what what this
seriously ominous you didn't kill her
did
you I love her so much Golem oh you just
wanted her to live
forever that's twist of fate right here
yeah
okay oh that's
mean that's sad oh that's really sad
this is not a kids movie it's the same
cage I take you away from here would you
like that oh
now great silhouette shot feels like a
classic
movie all right damn how long they how
long there's like no Community here at
all right now it's not much I know but
just they were the first
ones oh that is excellent that is
excellent
get away from my house oh watching the
history and development of all this
those criminals are attacking our house
now now they're they're just kids it's
Halloween no no no it's my house and
they're hurting me poor woman I will
never let anyone hurt
you oh go you she really is like being
terrorized I
know no oh there she goes in that's
the oh how
tragic so I finished the house she would
have wanted that she died but she didn't
leave her soul is truly tethered that's
why she hates the kids yeah that night
that one night of every PTSD yeah there
is a tragedy to this I had to
hey why do they keep singling out just
this house cuz it looks spooky she
attacks anyone who comes near I I'm I'm
coming
dear who oh this poor old guy I know
that you've been protecting us all these
years but now it's our turn to protect
you let her go yeah like you've lived
there long enough buddy I'll have no
one that's not
true oh now you're taking away her love
wa she does not like it she does not
like
it she can get up and oh my God it's
going to move around no
way it's a fullon monster movie now oh
she is
pissed yeah other people have to believe
you
now where's the rest of the neighborhood
yeah why is anyone running out being
like why is this house walking around on
the street maybe just try to communicate
to it I'll be all right and be like hey
we're not we it's okay
Constance is it killing the humans I
don't that's the confusing part is I
don't know where all the rest of the
people went
wow uh who threw
that hey h that's domestic
violence nice sweet you've been a bad
girl haven't you you've Hur people a man
the way they've managed to make it so
expression it with the whole House's
emotions and I have to make
things
ow oh he's going to blow her up I've
always done what's best for you haven't
I this be the right thing to
do oh oh no oh no she's going to eat
you leave alone get your grubby branes
off the old man clever this actually
came back around that's clever that's
really
[Music]
clever oh wow oh take this
what you have to help me please where's
the rest of the people that keeps it is
kind of distracting me that there's no
one else joining them to be like what's
going on going oh my God chimney leads
to the
heart that's easy just get on top of the
chimney you can do it no
[Music]
problem fantastic TJ get rid of that
thing oh there you go you drop it from
the crane into the chimney right I need
you to get the House Down Under that
crane piece of
cake I mean easier said than
[Music]
done oh my God it is crumbling
apart I think you did it chowder now you
still got to destroy the heart it has
the capability of reassembling yay yes
look at me ah here she goes again oh
that was your opportunity to go into the
chimney flat ground she's a strong woman
yeah you got to use the crane come
on wa it's taking a new shape look
cooler now she looks like the shape of
waterf fish now you ain't nothing you're
a shack you're an out
house you teller
chowder
[Music]
uh-oh Whoa man this could have been so
much easier if he just went up to that
[Music]
chimney I can't yes you
can she did it oh my God she made the
move first
[Music]
yeah
sorry the music does a really good job
of making this feel like a big huge
Adventure it seems spooky but I also
like have a feeling they're all going to
be okay
yeah crazy could cough me
that that's
perfect prove your necessity for being
in this movie
[Music]
oh it's like the
leaf stop
woo W that's
awesome this neighborhood cool is this
sucks they must have the best sleep
cycles or or like they're always inside
they all have they all wasted and asleep
air plugs and sleeping masks yep they
just got the whole shebang down they got
sound waves going on in the
background oh the ghost the
ghost man how are you still alive I'm
sorry Mr neor cracker about your
house and your wife yeah where's he
going to live now are your housewife
housewife we have been trapped for
45 years I thought it's longer we're
free thank you
[Music]
friend we're free she's like would you
like to buy some cookies cuz I'd like to
make some money off of
[Music]
you yeah see she lives
there whole neighborhood of Clueless
dumb asses oh now they come out now they
hear it trick treat we're going to need
a tricycle one tricycle coming up that's
cute there's my mom how is her mom not
like what happened to
you she normally wouldn't hang out with
boys like them but I think you will now
see you of course she will she kissed
him on the lips on top of a crane that's
a life moment you never
[Music]
forget
a I love trick-or-treating me too they
should do like a trick-or-treating for
adults I'm just going to go
anyway what oh he's back oh so she
didn't eat them anyone see my
kite wow what are okay wow she doesn't e
them she just swallows them keeps them
down there with the toy what a strange
Dan Harmon inter from Rick and
morte dang man
wow I I did like this movie a lot I
thought that like all of the tracking
shots the way that it's shot
cinematically where they're using like
but they used so many moves of like it's
a crane it's a crane shot there's a
dolly shot they use a lot of tracking
shots oh shut
up who is it
oh everyone's coming
back oh Nick Cannon he must be that
black
guy oh Maggie gillin that's her voice
God it was so hard she was the
babysitter oh John he right what do you
say shit's creek lady's name I need to
know it now inspect some candy
huha God bless her she's a genius all
right where's the car and that is how I
slayed that Mystical Dragon oh
yeah no way video game guys getting the
girl not so fast bones yeah times have
changed the sk's not like you he gives
me the respect I deserve and makes time
for me it's been it's been a couple
hours
yeah she moves
quick oh the dog
lives
go back to
Ping oh
cute
adorable anyway what were you saying
that you thought God nobody
cares so many camera moves in this movie
there's like a tracking shots a dolly
shot a crane shot and then like hand
moves and ins and outs and I I do like
that the way that they shot this movie
or decided to edit it was like every
shot was like camera's going to roll up
here and it's going to go up here and
we're going to pull Focus from here and
there it was very uh I would just say
creative it's not like they stuck to one
certain style like you're like you look
at Wes Anderson you know what you're
going to get there with this movie
you're like I don't know how they shot
it they just shot it with a bunch of
different camera angles and moves and it
kept it interesting cuz you kind of
never knew what you were going to what
you were going to get there and I guess
in animation not I guess in animation
it's obviously a lot easier to get very
cool shots without having to set up and
set up all these people and um I like
that and I also like that the music
didn't give me anxiety when it was
supposed to be spooky that it made it
feel more adventurous and that uh I I
like that it kind of it had a tone of
like it's going to get spooky and scary
but everyone's going to be okay and I
like that
um I liked it I thought I thought it was
fun yeah it's a fun movie what did you
think break it
down it's been long long days hasn't it
yeah yeah yeah it's been long but uh I I
liked it a lot that I do have my I do
have my criticisms I only on the table I
say that to keep you reeled in let him
he like okay oh what a way to hook us
I'm going to hear what GRE say it's good
first but I'm going to stick around
because he's teased us with there's
probably some things that he thought
could have been better or perhaps didn't
like I want to I want to hear that what
are they and then I guess I'll share M
I'll share them later share them later
you share the positives first but you
reel them in by by teasing them you got
some things we'll share our criticism
after by way for listen this on Apple or
Spotify would just watch monster house
which is a film produced by Steven
Spielberg and Robert zus and I got that
Vibe uh big time because there you know
zus has
done you know like the Polar
Express and Beowolf and the Christmas
carol one with Jim Carrey there's like a
lot of those animated movies that that
incorporated map yes that's what it
looks like the Christmas carol animation
like an Adventures of tin t yeah so I
was yeah that was bugging me like the
look of the animation I was like I've
seen this maybe only a few times and I'm
like it now I know yeah it had like that
that that combined mixture of something
that you might have seen from like those
Tim buron like likeo production company
mixed with that zca style yeah um and of
course with like the the amlin classic
you know perilous kid horror touch but
uh also with that sense of wonder in its
horror that I really liked the camera
work yeah I mean that was probably the
main thing we were talking about was
absolutely excellent here it constantly
felt like there was a presence with them
something watching them like the camera
felt like there was there was a
personality to it that at times you you
would get the impression that there's
there there is a spirit watching them at
all times uh I thought it was excellent
but but yeah just amazing tracking shots
and I would say the same thing for for
the works of like EV a Tintin and and uh
polar express the same time my
criticisms are kind of what I would feel
with those movies as well but before I
go there some more
positive wow um it's called monster
house and I really loved the tragic tale
love the title yeah I really love the
title we fill each other's sentences
that way we always finish
them I really love the title and it the
monster house really was that kind of
classic tragic tale you know when you
think about like the universal Monsters
of like
Frankenstein or creature of the Black
Lagoon there was always a tragic element
to them and that that made them more
human and relatable and you got that
sense early on that maybe this old guy
is really not such a bad guy that
there's something else underneath the
surface and sure enough um I Lov the
tragic tale that it it struck like I out
of anything it emotionally desire like
wanted me to connect to granted it comes
late into the film it was was successful
yeah yeah right it was that out of
anything to truly connect to on an
emotional level sad it was sad I cared
and um like the Arc of what's his name
Nebuchadnezzar was the old man nebar
that old man old man was call him old
man he's old guy in here um the old guy
I thought was a really touching story
that had that like gal de toro horror
fantasy quality about it that I really
loved and like we were saying during the
reaction the Monster House itself just
like I thought I thought the the the way
they would you would slowly get to know
it like okay is just a haunted house no
it's not or it seems like there's a
personality to it oh there's an actual
Anatomy to it like they they they let it
be revealed over time your understanding
of what this house what was going on and
then when you go into the house it is
like you're stepping inside of a body
you know yeah and I thought so I thought
that was really great like it can't
really see inside so it has to like feel
around right like the way you would feel
with your own body um yeah I thought I
thought that was all excellent I feel
like the way that they set her up what
was her name again
Clarice Oh I thought you were just going
to say right now I was like why don't I
know Cassandra
candra C Clarence listen Clarence when
CL when we saw Clarence okay and she's
at the circus and then it gives her like
that PTSD of obviously why she's hating
kids I really like that we got to the
explanation of it set up the character
so much but it's like the the subtext a
little bit of it is like the letting go
of of like your past and certain things
that you may be so connected to whether
it's someone who has died and you can't
I mean that's like a I know a larger way
more adult like metaphor that we're
dealing with but we did deal deal with
that here of like it he needed the help
which of of others to help him get out
of it and help to to let go of her so
that he could freely live um except it
made it really hard for him you can't
really let anybody get that close
because you know you're your wife who's
dead in the cement downstairs is going
to eat him um so tough struggle is real
but it's funny that she was eating all
these kids toys and eating mostly kids
who came around and knowing to shut up
around adults and cops but it was the
kids who actually saved him and Let Her
Go Let Her Spirit go and you know her
spirit was kind of happy because she was
dancing with him and then disappeared
and I'm like that was through the help
of the children they weren't all bad
yeah and I coun of those syllables on my
fingers I don't know why it's been it's
been a long day and I like to that it is
actually commits to its spookiness it
commits to its frightening qualities
like this really I would categorize like
a kid's horror movie and you don't
really see that you know I just watched
the Goosebumps movie for Jack Black and
that doesn't even strike it does not
even strike that chord it's just like
yes
a kids movie where this I'm like oh this
this really feels like there's Peril um
there's danger there's there's
frightening imagery you know and and I
love that they actually maintain that uh
and and it's kind of hard to find kid
horror now like you don't you don't
really get like at least on a big scale
you don't really get that so I really
like that the the the the criticism that
I have is that there's something that
leaves me detached and I kind of feel
this way with the with the other movies
I was listening to spec and I didn't
realize this was like a zamas film and
and until like they played the credits
at the end or like produced by one of
The Producers is that leaves me detached
is there's something specifically just
in the dialogue
interactions with uh with any of the
characters that kind of feels like no
real rhythm uh to the way it's either
captured or it just kind of feels like
flatly done like oh like there's Mo cap
so they're just shooting it right and
it's just and there's no life to it and
the writing of the dialogue is not as
clever or witty as I think the movie is
thinks it might be so I don't really
like the characters are like reasonably
likeable all of them are they're all
reasonably likable yeah uh but I don't
feel much life from them so they
always when you have such captivating
visuals when when stuff is happening
like going I guess the best example I
can give is what it's kind of unfair to
say this with a with a 2023 movie um
like across the like the spiderverse
movies where when it's just dialogue I'm
just I am still engaged where here when
the dialogue was happening like it just
kind of feels a little disconnected it's
kind of like when we watch monsters Inc
or minions no not Monsters Inc I'm sorry
minions we watched right and we said it
was either minions or a different movie
weable movies one of the Despicable
movies but we made the comment saying
that it felt like in this ADR in the in
the voice over work that it's as if they
put them in a room and they were moving
around in the same environment yeah
rather than just like here's a mic and
I'm doing this character and I'm reading
it for for just the dialogue which maybe
this is kind of what they were doing I
forget what movie we we said that we
said that for How to Train Your Dragon
yes but it's it's map so they have to
have been in the same room right yeah
you're
I um I don't know I maybe I think it's
really I don't know then there's a flat
type of level of Direction I think the
way it's delivered like thrown away more
yeah or even the way the C like the
camera just feels like it's lazily
plopped on when usually when they're
just talking yeah and so there is a lack
of Rhythm to there's like there's no
editing energy to it there's and then so
it kind of loses spark to me and then
and I just I guess I'm not a big fan of
just the way a lot of the the dialogue
overall is is done MH and I don't know
if there were some really funny parts
but I were some really funny part there
were some really funny parts um but I
it's just kind of like a dry en that I
guess if I have to summarize in this
it's a dry energy um to to the way
that's done and so that leaves me just
going can we get back to like the the
the SP the spookiness yeah can we get
back to the house like the house like
just get back to the the stuff you know
where where I was never truly engaged
with any of the and and normally in like
any kind of horror movie or horror
adjacent the thing that makes it truly
gripping is is the stuff outside of the
horror you're invested in so then when
the horror stuff is happening you're
just it it is the cherry on top and here
I was like just get back to the the the
fun spooky stuff because I'm not really
that interested in the charact like they
should have that stranger things effect
where you really like the personalities
of these guys AG so then when they're
going into the dangers of it all you you
you really like even if you're not
knowing like their whole backstory or
whatever you just really like their
personalities right and here it was just
kind of ringing a little flat just
because of the way and I think it had
something to do with the combination of
the the way they directed specifically
with the camera work around them yeah
cuz the camera work got really
interesting anytime it would not be
people talking right it it moved around
like a a bit more and made everything
else seem much larger than life than
when they were talking it kind of like
dampened out a little bit yeah and if
all the tropes of like chowder just
being like the funny like chubby kid you
know uh you that funny sidekick chubby
the girl pops up and then the lead I
forget what his name was I knew the only
name I know is Chows uh but I do agree
in in the sense that we never really got
to know the lead character as much of
just being like oh he's being left at
home fine he gets a babysitter but um
yeah I don't know that I cared too much
if whether he was going to
be whether they all lived or not I guess
I was more emotionally attached to the
mystery yeah and like wanting to know
the house and the lore and like I said
the old guy stuff came in very late but
but I was really into that me too you
know I was into the old guy stuff in the
Clarance obviously and that's yes
definitely her name it's not and this
movie is almost two decades old so I
know I'm giving two decades 2006
apparently whoa okay so that's why it
feels because it just it does feel
outdated with the way that there the
characters in here uh you you wouldn't
be able to do that today is kind of
there was some stuff going on in there
and so now it makes sense that's 2006 um
but uh yeah I guess it's it's setting up
the foundation of this film wasn't like
oh you're going to care whether they
live or die we kind of always felt like
these kids will always be fine but
they're our way in to this home to
figure out the heart of the story which
was the heart of Clarence and the old
guy letting her go but I do agree if
they had gotten to it a little bit
sooner they were just like a resource to
get in there but um yeah if maybe we had
gotten to it a little bit sooner maybe
it would
LED I don't know to us carrying a little
bit more right off the bat I'm not sure
and I do think it needed a bit of that
stranger things Vibe where you get the
sense of Hawkins Community yeah it it
does become distracting when you're like
there's so much emphasis on this house
in the neighborhood but you don't get a
sense of the neighborhood at all right
but when when the ending does show you
there's a neighborhood there's a
neighborhood they don't they came out at
the end I know yeah and they have like
he could hear the the door the call
ringing across the street cop could hear
the house too the cops could hear and
then suddenly the the house is coming to
life and thrashing everywhere and no
one's doing jack or scared or like
what's happening you know and I think
you I do think it needed that I I I I
found it distracting it's not just like
a logical plot hole thing like when when
your setup is about the house in the
neighborhood we need to see the
neighborhood we do and it would have
been nice for the whole Community to see
old
man not being shown as like old man is
not just being old mean man he's being
that for a reason and if the whole
Community has to come together to be
like he needs to let this house go
because it's Clarence uh needs to be let
go and released yeah um would have been
nice for the whole Community to see that
he's not mean he just he was trying to
protect you all wouldn't that have been
such like a a spee moment if it's like
at the end of the community like what's
this house it's walking around and then
he has to yell like I was just trying to
protect you or if the kids did it for me
or the kids did it like he's just trying
to protect us and then the whole
Community is like wait what is she I
don't know they explain it Clarence is
in there her name's definitely Clarence
it's not um I question it every time you
said it i' just like yeah it's not it's
definely um that that could have been
fun for the I do agree with you like
they they came they came at very
convenient times of when it was happy
world the neighborhood is out and their
trick-or-treating uh but during the
crazy times it was like dead town I
don't know why it was like I think there
was a lot of cre visual experimentation
though that it seemed like a lot of the
stuff they were doing story-wise to help
justify a lot of the things they wanted
to experiment with what they could bring
to life like the real character of the
movie is the Monster House the real
character of this movie is the animation
the real character of the movie is the
camera work and and yeah I agree I love
the music too and and I think that um I
the thing is like what I I feel I do
feel strongly about the things I I did I
I criticize however I do feel strongly
about the things I really did like or
love so to me I'm like no I still Edge
towards yeah this is a great movie for
especially kids to watch kids to watch
to get an attainable horror film um
around Halloween time like this is a
great this is like a this has that
Halloween spooky spirit that I think is
really fun um and I think the animation
is and those moments is gorgeous and the
things that I think are really that
really work work really strong so yeah
no I would definitely recommend it U for
that fact it's just yeah there's like
other things like a could have been
could have been like a perfect film of
of like Wonder but didn't quite capture
that still really really did enjoy it
there was still a little bit of more
story to be done but other than that
like they did well with what they had
yeah man wrap us up T while I set us up
to
I'm going to wrap it up by just saying I
had a great time here with you watching
Monster House sir and um that's it you
guys know to be super sexy we got to do
a patron shout out listen we love you be
cool be kind be nice leave a comment
tell us how cool we are tell us how much
you like this movie what maybe what you
didn't like to I don't know what else
should we watch stuff like you guys know
what to write in the comments like as
long as you're cool nice kind you WR
whatever you want tell me I'm
pretty uh okay let's do a patron shout
out get to it all right so here's what
we're gonna
do we're gonna do okay thank two people
to there's two people here I think could
be understanding we're behind on our
shout out so I got to combine a couple
great we're going to do it spooky time
we're going to have a great creative
time here we're going to put Eric
Horseman the man with the real reject
tattoo he has an actual real reject
tattoo cool I know I want to see it in
person when you die can you put it in
your will that you have to tear it off
your F some they have to like tear it
off your flesh and send it to me put it
in a bottle with that like fluid that
keeps it alive forever that cereal then
it can grow tentacles and then this is
already part of your shout out and then
Ana Oliva who we've met in person quite
a couple of times real sweetheart and uh
always had a crush on John no not not as
big of a
fan so I wanted to do a shout out here
with of the thing that's going to
replace all screenwriters chat gbt so um
I wanted to do one of Eric Horseman and
Ana Oliva together yeah and then how
they would spend their Halloween time so
we're going to need some things here all
right pumpkin all right hold on hold on
hold on you got to properly prompt this
thing fine cuz it doesn't know how to
you got to be its director I was ready
but keep that in mind okay I have a
YouTube channel
where I need to shout
out
two of my
patrons ano Liva and Eric
Horseman write me a shout out about them
meeting on
Halloween and what goes goes down no
what you mean including pumpkins yes
ghosts including pumpkins
ghosts and Reese's ghouls Reese's
candy and a good time and and a good
time
period some notes about their
personality
wow as
well Eric loves
horror Star Wars
animals
works at a
hotel and is
very very
sarcastic you Eric is an absolute
sweetheart from
Texas who has a crush on John Humphrey
from real reject that's so cute works at
a bar loves her family a Ana Eric also
has a good
heart all right this is a novel is it
ending yet oh good hey everyone as the
Moonlight sets the stage this Halloween
I've got a spooky tale to share with all
of you about our two phenomenal patrons
Ana Oliva and Eric hman is that oh my
God this is go I'm only uh a foggy
Halloween night in a small town pumpkins
glow in every doorstep Anda our Texas
Gem has a golden heart with the lon star
state is setting up a pop-up bar for the
night and know it's not just any bar
it's Halloween themed filled with
concoctions that seem too Eerie to drink
oh in the corner a jukebox is playing
Halloween Classics and if you listen
closely you can hear her huming along
dreamily thinking about John Humphrey
from the real
rejects enter Eric horor ficado and a
sarcastic smirk with a sarcastic smirk
and a Star Wars cloak because why decide
between and SciFi when you can
have
both as he approaches the bar he
sarcastically comments this doesn't look
like a hotel I work at as to which an
laugh and pours him a drink and they
both Bond over their love for animals
and family and Eric sharing Hotel tales
that would make even the bravest Souls
chuckle with
trepidation suddenly a group of ghost
schools
appears challenging them to a racist
camp Cy eating contest Anissa with her
inherent Texans Texan competitiveness
and Eric not one to back down from a
challenge he Dives right in the two show
the spirits that the two show the
spirits that humans too can hold their
own in a Halloween especially if it's
sarcastically presented did you say that
no did I miss you skipped like a whole
sentence I missed it listen the night
continues with laughter laughter
laughter mischief and a whole lot of
candy the one once Eerie fog now seems
like a blanket of camaraderie embracing
everyone in his worm so here Ana and
Eric two amazing Souls who not only
support the channel but also know how to
have a good time May Halloween be filled
with as much fun goals and
races as this magical night wow
whoa you
guys wow we're being replaced that was a
lot I don't think so because I'm going
to tell you right now I could have given
a shout out and it would have been a
quarter of that and justce fun okay I
tell you I tell you that right now
people were asleep halfway through my
reading of this novel okay damn so we
love you all there's your shout out and
can we go home and go to sleep now
please for the love of God yeah end it
for me
pleas